where motivation is low that's what  discipline kicks in  anybody who's done something noteworthy  worth their lives all have one thing in  common  and that's discipline I encourage you to  just write down your goals  starting off your day with reading your  goals and dreams aloud gives you a boost  of positive energy  this energy can take you to places you  couldn't even imagine  now a cheat code to ensure that you're  staying disciplined to whatever you're  striving for is to prime your  environment for Success which brings me  to a very important step of the high  level mindset remove all negative people  out of your life immediately if you're  talking about your dreams and goals and  they give small sarcastic remarks  boot them  don't let someone else's negativity  cancel out your light